vamos al repaso de la información
económica con jorge hurtado en france24
jorge otra vez un saludo y vamos a
iniciar con los indicadores cómo se
comportan los mercados después del
descubrimiento de omicron en eeuu así
ángel ahora vamos a iniciar con wall
street
ahí el extender en poor perdió fuerza
tras haber subido casi un 2 por ciento
al principio del día las aerolínea en
los operadores de crucero y los hoteles
cayeron europa las acciones registraron
su mayor sesión en casi seis meses ya
que los impresores recuperaron los
valores golpeados en las últimas
sesiones por la nueva variante y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo y
la bolsa de chile cerraron a la baja por
los problemas internos
y también tenemos buenas previsiones
para la economía colombiana así es según
las proyecciones de la organización para
la cooperación y el desarrollo económico
conocida como sede colombia mostrará los
mejores números de la región el próximo
año según la ocde la economía colombiana
crecerá 5,5 por ciento de 2022 y
reducirá ese ritmo al 3,1 por ciento en
2023 esta es la mejor proyección que
brindó el organismo para latinoamérica
incluso superior a brasil cuya economía
retrocederá en el 2022 pero el informe
advierte que el empleo no va a un buen
ritmo y sólo volverá a las tasas de
ocupación prepandémicas hasta mitad del
año 2023 asimismo la inflación de
colombia se ubica en 4,58 por ciento se
mantendrá por encima del 3% durante el
próximo año y comenzará a bajar hasta en
el 2023 según la ocde el próximo
gobierno colombiano que asuma en 2022
tendrá que implementar nuevos cambios
fiscales para mejorar estos problemas de
capacidades adquisitivas esto dijo el
ministro de hacienda y crédito público
de colombia josé manuel restrepo
escuchemos
es de destacar la manera como la ocde
señala que este crecimiento se va a
generar con una gran fortaleza en el
consumo privado destacando el avance que
se ha logrado en materia de vacunación
masiva
un énfasis en las exportaciones y la
manera como las exportaciones van a ser
motor de crecimiento
y jorge hablando de la ocde ese
organismo también presentó sus
expectativas de crecimiento mundial asia
y sobre todo modelo las expectativas de
recuperación económica por varios
factores entre ellos la inflación que
afecta el mundo la falta de mano de obra
y nuevas variantes del coi como la que
estamos viendo la organización redujo en
dos décimas su previsión de crecimiento
para el mundo en 2021 y lo ubicó en 56
por ciento y aumentó las expectativas
para 2022 hasta el 45 por ciento la
organización también bajo las
previsiones para las dos economías más
grandes del mundo con respecto a su
informe de septiembre para eeuu
actualizó a 5.6 por ciento y para china
8.1 por ciento la zona euro sufrió una
décima a la baja en latinoamérica la
auto mejoró las perspectivas de
argentina con una subida de la actividad
del 8 por ciento en 2021 el organismo
está preocupado por la inflación causada
por los costos en la energía y los
problemas en la cadena de suministros
ayer el presidente de la reserva federal
de eeuu e incluso dijo que debe de se
debe dejar mencionar la palabra
transitorio cuando nos referimos
a este fenómeno económico para el cierre
turquía el presidente de thai verduga
defendió su controversial política
económica con las tasas de interés hacia
en el everton ban que se declaró enemigo
de los tipos de interés en su país
defiende que lo correcto es bajarlos
para controlar la inflación cuando los
bancos centrales del mundo hacen
totalmente lo contrario una anotación
breve según economista es una baja tasa
de interés busca promover el crédito y
por lo tanto la actividad económica
en cambio una alta tasa de interés
previene que la economía se caliente
ayuda de alguna forma contra la
inflación en turquía el banco central
realizó una serie de recortes de los
tipos de interés desde septiembre a
pesar de una inflación que ronda el 20
por ciento algo que ha provocado masivas
protestas en contra del gobierno según
el presidente los altos tipos de interés
provocan una alta inflación y prometió
mantener el tipo principal bajo la libra
que es la moneda oficial ha perdido casi
un 30% de su valor frente al dólar en un
mes escuchemos que dijo el presidente
erdogán
hemos abandonado la política monetaria
basada en altas tasas de interés y el
cambio hemos cambiado una estrategia de
crecimiento basada en inversiones empleo
producción y exportaciones pero estimé y
drogas ya tensas hablan y cuál es la
cifra del día
angela la cifra del día de 25 6 % es
aumentaron las remesas interanual es en
méxico entre enero y octubre méxico
recibió 42 mil 168 millones de dólares
en remesas 25 6% más respecto al mismo
período del 2020 graciasjorge y
continúen en france24 buenas noches
[Música]